so
the guard says to me look
i've looked into this and he's missed
his flight
he's got to be rescheduled but there's
still time to get your flights
they take me out again and i i'm like
whoa
yeah yeah so get to the airport i'm sat
in the van
the guard says i know i say i want to i
want to
um use the toilet i need to pee you know
i've been hours of this i've not had a
chance to pee
right he's like you're not going to try
anything funny are you i'm like no you
know we just want to go home
so he takes me into a toilet
and he chains me to a like a
railing thing next to the toilet he
changed me to it
well he goes to pee and
i pee and then he brings me out
and he's still like going you're not
gonna try anything funny you're not
training funny i'm not no i just want to
go home
so i had a guy i brought a guy on the
other you know a few weeks ago and he
he he just looked really funny and
shifty and
the captain wouldn't let him on the
plane and he had to be rescheduled you
know you're not gonna try anything
no no you know i'm a business graduate
i'm a stock market guy i won't try
so it takes me on the plane he goes i'm
going to put you on first so you don't
scare the passengers
and there's a cabin crew from london
and they talk to me like i was a human
being it was the first time in almost
six years
anyone has taught me like i was a human
being
and i couldn't believe it i was like i
was just
melting that a civilian
i talked to me like i was a human being
and they showed me where to sit and i
got over there
and then all the passengers get on and
after being around hurry sweaty men for
six years you know i could smell the
women's perfume and all this stuff
but i was a bit institutionalized one of
the mistakes i made was
i put my hand up and i asked a female
member of the cabin crew
if i could go to the toilet like the
toilet's right there you don't need to
ask and i'm going red
i was paranoid that i stung because i'd
been in transportation for days
so i wanted to have a bird bath in
prison
if you can't get yourself because of all
the lockdowns you have a bird bath which
means
you basically just scrub your armpits
and scrub your ass and your [ __ ] yeah
so so go in there have my bird bath come
back
out and um
they got some stupid movies on and the
flights go in and
um we land at gatwick
there's actually some footage of my
youtube channel of me in the car
in the car and meeting my parents at the
airport
my mom's praying we're having a hug i'm
all stubbled out
my face is just completely pale and
shell shocked you can see i've been
through some intense stuff
and my mom's crying and it's just so
nice to give my mom a hug
um right away they took me to the indian
restaurant
i ordered chicken tikka masala my former
favorite but
i got the gag reflex because of the dead
rats in the mystery beach slot
i think i told you about in part one
yeah i got the gag reflex i couldn't eat
it and to this day i've stayed
vegetarian because of that
i did some bbc interviews and um
a a a counselor with a big reputation in
london
he had an office out of harley street
which is very prestigious
contacted the bbc and said look
he heard me tell the bbc the cockroach
story and other stories i've told you
he said look um i want to contact this
guy
and offer him a job speaking in the
schools
and i i was blessed that such good
people came into my life to help me get
my public speaking career going and get
my
my books going 13 books now just
published pablo esco's story part 3 this
week that's my 13th book
so he offers me this job speaking in
schools um
i said look i'm a bit institutionalized
i gotta get my head straight i really
appreciate this
but it'll give me a bit of time to
settle down before speaking of school i
think it was about a year and a half
later before i took him up on that job
situation my mom said i was like a puppy
dog falling around the house waiting for
orders
and in the end i i moved down south into
the house
of one of my former xc suppliers mike
hot wheels
he's one of the main characters in party
time he um
was supplying ecstasy out of la to me
before i started go through holland
he was a rave dj as well out of
manchester
which is you know near where i was i
grew up
he's 10 years older than me so he's a
bit of a mentor for me
as i was coming up in the drug scene and
mike got arrested in prison in the feds
in america
he was he ended up um and
he his case was running a few years
before mine
so he got released before me got this
house in guildford
and um he's like just moving with me and
because that's near london
that's how i was able to make the
necessary connections
to get my career back on track
now what did you do to get your career
back on track so what did you do to make
money
i mean obviously there's a big mental
shift for you you were
uh like you said you were full of
testosterone you were all about making
making millions of dollars you were
doing whatever you were doing coke
ecstasy all that stuff
and like fast-paced lifestyle just like
the wolf of wall street
and there was obviously a huge
transformation that happened to you
inside prison so
now what is your outlook when it comes
to
making money or rebuilding your wealth
so i went from that greed is good motto
to just taking it as it came
and trying to rebuild my life from
scratch and i do enjoy my therapist said
i enjoy building things up but then i
knocked them back
down again when i got to get to the top
so i knew i was not going to knock it
down again i was just going to make slow
and steady progress
in life now it was in the maximum
security jail my writing got smuggled
out
back in 2003 2004
but that caused the blog john's jill
journal
attracted international media attention
to sheriff joe piles hellhole
and alliteration did approach me about
a book and when i got out
that literary agent died so then i'm
like contacting
literary agents and publishers saying
i've got the best story in the world and
the best right in the world
didn't have a clue what i was doing i
was just burning bridges completely
so i won a short story contest
that my mum had entered me into through
a charity called prisoners abroad
and i forgot not even entered it it was
about [ __ ] slinger in super max
oh yeah i remember that story yeah yeah
well this was a whole different [ __ ]
slinger story oh really
yeah yeah um that was made into a short
story
um it was about a white guy was in the
super max and this big [ __ ] slinger
um it was about battle between them two
that they had going on for a long time
and what happened
so i win a short story contest i'm asked
to read at the royal festival hall
and the people who have won this award
through are called the curseless trust
so prisoners abroad entered it cursed
the trust gave me the award
and these wonderful people some of the
money from my books goes to them now to
this day because they just do such great
work helping prisoners rehabilitate
through art that's what curse the trust
do
they based out of london they put me on
their mentor scheme
so i published overcame and
met me every month in the london museum
and stuff
and within um within a year
of this lady working her magic i had a
literary agent
and that guy he
helped me me fine-tune as well and then
he got me a deal with random house
uh who published originally published my
life story as a trilogy before i i got
the rights back
now i'm thinking right you know
the the author the term author
has associated with it the biggest
misconception by the public
of income authors are actually some of
the lowest paid people in the world if
you look at the average income for an
offer
people think of jk rowling stephen king
do you think everybody everybody's in
office making that much money but
they're not
most offers are broke and i have to
learn that the hard way then i'm
thinking well no for now
i'm gonna make all this money yeah
so i'm selling a hundred thousand pounds
worth of books a year through rent for
random house
we're doing that a lot i'm doing book
signings and by book signing i mean
me and my mom are in the store all day
long from nine o'clock till five o'clock
handing out leaflets and putting people
in headlocks
making them by the bloody book they're
not all lined up at a table because i'm
so famous and i could just
sit there and sign books and leave after
an hour me and my mom
we just oh man we went up and down the
country doing that
wow selling a hundred thousand pounds
for books a year
that's like 120 000
i got a check every six months some
random house how much do you think that
check was
uh ten thousand dollars true
two thousand dollars jesus
christ yeah so it took me a long time
man to rebuild
and to make an income decent enough to
start investing in my own podcast and
stuff like that
that's kind of how a lot of people have
to start though i mean when you start
fresh in something like that you kind of
have to
you got to start without no you have you
have no recollect you don't know how
anything works you have no connections
you have no leverage
you just you're fresh out of prison and
that's how you learned it took me 10
years
to become a millionaire stock market
took me 10 years for my initial drug
purchases
for me to be doing the millions in the
ecstasy trafficking business
um so you know it's took equally that
long to become a best seller on amazon
i